welcome to the Daily climate show coming
up today
8 billion and Counting as the global
population hits another Milestone we'll
examine what it could mean for the
climate
with just three full days left to go at
cop27 we'll look at what might make and
more importantly not make the summit's
final statement
[Music]
how the world's 15 biggest meat and
dairy companies are responsible for more
methane than most large countries
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now the global population officially
passed 8 billion people today amid
increasing fears over what the impact of
the sheer number of people on Earth
means for the planet and its climate
that number has more than doubled in the
past 50 years in 1972 it was just 3.8
billion but despite that the population
growth rate has actually been slowing
over the past six decades let's take a
look it peaked in 1964 at more than 2.2
percent every year but it's now less
than one percent every year a
significant drop the UN projects
population the population will Peak at
around 10.4 billion people in the 2080s
and remain at that level until
2100
now in sub-Saharan Africa around
738 million people already live without
adequate Food Supplies and the
population is projected to Jump by a
further 95 percent by the middle of the
century
now our Africa correspondent yusra
albigir joins us from Lagos now that's
the most populated city in the most
populated African country Nigeria yusra
good to see you at what impact is this
population growth having on the planet
and indeed Africa which is already so
impacted by climate change
I mean the two unextricably late and
we've met communities here that have
been affected by both just this year
Nigeria has seen the worst flooding in
decades more than 600 people killed more
than a million homeless and it's
affected 94 out of 36 sorry out of 34
out of 36 States here but we're now in
Lagos and Lagos as you said is most
populated city in Africa but it's also a
group of islands connected by bridges in
the Atlantic Ocean and we've met
Waterfront communities here who are
suffering from lack of affordable living
space facing demolition by the
government but also rising sea levels
that could see Lagos Disappear by 2050.
extraordinary facts and very Stark
images yusra thank you so much for that
update thank you
in some of the other climate stories
making the news today here are the
headlines methane emissions produced by
15 of the world's biggest meat and dairy
companies surpassed those of several of
the world's biggest countries that's
according to a new study now a report
for the institute for agriculture and
trade policy and changing markets
Foundation calculated that the companies
have emitted more methane than Russia
Canada and Australia and more than 80
percent of the eu's entire methane
footprint that's quite something methane
which is mainly emitted by cows traps
heat 80 times more than carbon dioxide
the head of Scottish Power has warned it
might reconsider its investment plans if
the government imposes a windfall tax on
power generators in Thursday's Autumn
statement Scottish Power is one of the
country's biggest green energy companies
by virtue of the wind farms it owns and
Keith Anderson told times any windfall
Levy should provide tax breaks for
investment in Renewables and his company
could slow or reduce its UK investment
if any Levy is as tough as that imposed
on oil and gas producers
the environment Minister Lord Goldsmith
has got into a row on social media with
Extinction Rebellion after being pursued
by an 11 year old climate activist at
[ __ ] 27. the Supreme kangu Gym who you
may have seen interviewed on Sky News
last week was asking him about just stop
oil protesters who were arrested in the
UK Extinction Rebellion then accused
Lord Goldsmith's Aid of pushing
liziprium he responded on Twitter by
accusing the organization of bullying a
civil servant who can't answer back
now staying with cop27 and we're getting
to the sharp end of the summit there are
only three scheduled days to go but the
possibility remains that it could go
into extra time as cop26 did last year
in Glasgow
politicians and negotiators have now
begun the attempt to find common ground
for a deal but the summit's Egyptian
hosts today acknowledge many sticking
points remain unresolved with the
possibility of this cop extending into
the weekend now being openly discussed
well Skye's climate reporter Victoria
Seabrook joins me now from charmel
Sheikh Victoria good to see you again
just three full days left to go until
the end of cop
and why are talks on 1.5 degrees of
warming now hanging in the balance
yes that's exactly it so you'll remember
that 1.5 degrees that is the crucial
goal which up until relatively recently
there has been Global consensus on that
we need to try to limit warming to 1.5
degrees to avoid to avoid the very worst
impact of climate breakdown but now
there is a big fight going on about
whether that even makes it into the the
final deal the cover text which is the
the key political document that comes
out of these talks and it kind of sets
the direction and the mood for the rest
of the world to kind of get in line
behind other Industries and so on and
I've been speaking to senior diplomats
negotiators and they've been telling us
that it's country
oh it looks like even realistic it's
even achievable today
Victoria we lost you briefly there so
I'm just going to either let you
continue with what you were saying or if
you were nearing the end of it um also
bring us up to speed on on what was also
being discussed at cop which is the fact
that there's not only a battle over the
text but over the whole Narrative of
this summit tell us more about that
yes exactly so I was just going to say
that it's countries like India and China
who have been questioning whether one
and a half degrees is even achievable
but as you say there's a battle not just
for the text but uh for the narrative
going on a bit of war of words and so
we've got countries briefing now
everyone trying to position themselves
as a climate leader it's quite
remarkable where you think where we've
come in the last few years that now no
one wants to be seen as the climate
laggard so we're being told that it's
India and China who are disrupting
things a bit but actually if you were
India and China you might say well hang
on a minute yes we're big emitters China
is the is the biggest at the moment
India is third but actually when you
look at those emissions per head it's
much smaller and the developed world has
actually sort of eaten up the global the
the budget for the emissions that we can
that we can get away with if we are
going to limit bombing down to 1.5
degrees and let's not forget that places
like India have been forced to burn more
coal yeah because of the gas prices
they've effectively outbid for their gas
by Europe so it does make things harder
for places like India that doesn't wash
with very vulnerable Nations small
island States for example who say we
have to do absolutely everything right
now
okay Victoria thanks so much for the
update we realize there's so much detail
to stay across but it really is so
important thank you so much for joining
us thank you
before we go a reminder that Tom Heap
will be presenting a special climate
show this weekend from charmel Shake
focusing on the end of cop27 and what if
anything gets achieved and you can watch
this on Saturday and Sunday at 3 30 in
the afternoon or again at 7 30 in the
evening and that is all from us for
today you can join us again at the same
time tomorrow thanks for watching
foreign